there's certainly no frills at novak
djokovic's hotel in melbourne his fans
have kept a vigil here as the world
number one is detained by the
authorities
his family say he was brought here and
put into a cramped bedroom that he's
sharing with insects
people seeking refuge in australia are
also held here so there's demonstrations
outside
inside djokovic is now waiting for a
court hearing on monday it's um it's
absolutely disgusting 100 for
a man of his status um who's contributed
so much to this country to be treated
like this and being put in this little
hotel djokovic thought he had a medical
exemption before he left europe but when
border force officials at melbourne
airport wanted the evidence to show why
he hasn't been vaccinated it wasn't
accepted it is not appropriate for me to
go into mr jokovich's own medical
history that would not be a fair thing
for us to do that is a day of matters
for him to discuss in terms of his own
medical history
but what i all i can say is that the
evidence for medical exemption that was
provided was found to be insufficient
the other star turns arriving at this
tournament are all now settling into
their preparation almost all of them
vaccinated and welcome
in some way i i feel
sorry for him
but at the same time
he know he knew the conditions since
a lot of months ago so
he makes his own decision
the american player tennis sandgren has
played in 10 australian opens he's
reached two quarter finals but his
decision not to get vaccinated means
he's watching this tournament from home
in tennessee you just
make the best decision that you can for
for yourself and um
i haven't lost a moment of sleep over it
um i i feel good about it i feel like
uh
you know it's a potentially slippery
road we're going down if if we start
mandating things like this and and we're
being forced to take things that we
don't want to take what would you do if
you were now in novak's position
i'd probably go home
i'd probably go home i wouldn't want to
play him anyway let alone when he's been
locked up in a in a cage quote unquote
for you know a few days
whether djokovic even hits a ball in
australia is now uncertain his team
wants to move him to a more comfortable
apartment but for now he is stuck in a
system that has given him no special
treatment
tom parmenter sky news